from the very first time I learned about
the existence of social security one
thing was made abundantly clear social
security is that's right Social
Security's doomed status has been the
fodder of news anchors and cable pundits
for so long that many people don't even
question it as a result many young
Americans are starting to worry whether
we'll ever see a dime of the taxes that
will be intuitive and this fear isn't
unique to America there are billions of
people that are paying into similar
programs all over the world from Albania
to Sim Bob way and when people's future
income is messed with bad things can
happen
remember the riots in Greece a few years
ago so is social security and income
source we should count on a retirement
or should we just kiss those dollars
goodbye and hope our grandparents enjoy
it while they can the earliest recorded
beneficiary of the Social Security
retirement benefit was a mr. Ernest
Ackerman a retired motormen from Ohio
Ernest applied for a one-time lump-sum
benefit of 17 cents the day after Social
Security program began considering he
only paid five cents into the system
during that single day I say he made out
alright in the decades since the program
has expanded to touch more Americans
lives than any other government program
with 169 million people paying in and 61
million receiving Bennett
instead of the lump sum payment Ernest
and his peers received the program
promises retirees an income as long as
they live
presuming they paid in long enough in
2019 the average Social Security
retirement benefit is one thousand four
hundred sixty one dollars per month the
maximum benefit you can collect is two
thousand eight hundred sixty one dollars
a month and in order to receive any
credit you're required to earn at least
one thousand three hundred sixty dollars
per quarter for forty quarters
aka ten years with so many lives and
dollars on the line it's no wonder that
people tend to panic when they hear
reports that the Social Security trust
fund is set to run out of money
according to the trustees report funds
for retirement benefits are currently
set to be depleted in the Year 2034 so
was your uncle Jim right all along when
he blamed that president he doesn't like
for stealing the funds from our
retirement are we all gonna end up
eating cat food in our golden years that
is highly unlikely for starters Social
Security was designed to be a
pay-as-you-go system that means current
workers tax payments go to pay current
retirees this is different than
something like a corporate pension
company pensions go into a big
investment pool and need to be funded in
advance just in case the company later
goes out of business but in 1984
President Reagan made some big changes
that resulted in the program bringing in
more money than it paid out and this
excess stock piled into what became
known as the Social Security trust fund
one of the most popular myths
surrounding Social Security is the
belief that somebody Congress George
Bush Barack Obama raided the coffers of
this fund this is a false statement the
nearly three trillion dollar surplus
that the trust fund accumulated over the
past three decades hasn't been stolen
rated or pilfered it's been invested
rather than earns zero percent interest
on your retirement savings the trustees
decided to invest in special base unit
bonds from the Treasury which earn an
average interest of two
percent per year bonds are technically a
form of borrowing but it's a long way
from the federal government pillaging
your retirement so why are so many
people worried about the future of
Social Security well Americans are
living longer and having fewer children
right now 14% of the population is over
65 by the year 2080 that number will
grow to 23% that means more people
drawing from the system and fewer people
paying in the year 2018 was the first
time in 34 years that the program
actually paid out more than it took in
that can only go on for so long the
trustees currently predict the fund to
be completely empty by 2034 so what
happens if nothing changes by then is it
back to cat food thankfully the whole
system doesn't crumble once the trust
fund runs out of money that's because
the system is still primarily
pay-as-you-go and current taxes will be
able to take care of most of the
benefits retirees would continue to get
benefits but they would have to be
reduced taxes from those future workers
will only use recover 79 percent of
retirees benefits when the money runs
dry while that's not awesome it's nice
to know that if we don't make any
changes you can still count on the check
it'll just be twenty to twenty-five
percent reduced by the time you retire
the good news is that we still have 15
years to create a solution to rising
life expectancies and lower birth rates
there are several possible paths to
fixing the shortfall the simplest and
inevitable outcome if we don't find a
better way is to reduce benefits to
match income from payroll taxes simple
yes but most folks don't want their
retirement just after a lifetime of
paying into the system a second option
would be to simply increase what
taxpayers pay into the system the
current Social Security tax is twelve
point four percent half of which is paid
by you and half by your employer and
income above one hundred and twenty
thousand nine hundred dollars is not
taxed for Social Security at all
lawmakers could increase the percentage
paid in or raise the limit where Social
Security
stays out surprisingly voters seem open
to doing this 77% of people say raising
taxes is worth it in order to preserve
Social Security for future generations
cutting entitlements and raising taxes
tends to make your average lawmaker
sweat a little bit so another solution
that avoids both would be to raise the
age of retirement for younger workers
the full retirement age was originally
62 when the program began and has since
been raised to 67 for anyone born after
1960 we're living longer so it might
make sense for retirement checks to
begin later we could also reduce or
eliminate the benefit for wealthy
Americans or we could simply abolish the
whole government program and privatize
retirement plans making workers
completely responsible for their own
retirement but considering the
frightening Leeloo savings rate of
Americans seems like a stretch 8 in 10
Americans believe that Social Security
is good for the country and nearly 9 in
10 say it's now more important than ever
it affects more people than any other
federal program and has one of the
highest favorability ratings it's nice
to know that even if lawmakers can't
agree on any of these solutions we can
still rely on and that's our two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description if you would like to
support us on patreon what would you
like to see lawmakers do to our Social
Security program let us know in the
comments whoa
you